this is the Mets Northwest area task
force on the front line of the fight
against knife crime and gang violence
we've been regrouped and we're now on
the way to new him where last week there
was a murder which involved the knife
and we're going to execute a warrant
search warrant a high-risk address which
is known for drug use the officers will
force their way into this crack den are
wearing full protection as information
from Murder Squad detectives suggest the
possibility of weapons inside three
people inside the flats have been
handcuffed as officers search the rooms
within minutes they found a samurai
sword an axe and a knife the detectives
believed to be the murder weapon one of
the suspects and we believe is quite
addictive drugs out and weed night
people because this officer seen drugs
in the door as you find my foot as you
can see and an out on the ledge there's
a bag for things 20 bags of cannabis not
move by the Taser and if you kick off
you'll get tasered do you understand
this is the raw reality of knife crime
which has shown a significant rise
across the country and today nationwide
police are on the offensive with high
profile operations to get knives off the
streets
Lorraine Jones life was torn apart by
knife crime she now helps run a boxing
gym and community project in South
London set up in the memory of her son
Duane who was stabbed to death as he
went to help another young man being
chased by a gang of youths it feels like
yesterday it feels like you're you're
living a dream and you just want to wake
up
feel like I've earn well I have got a
broken heart it's disabled us we're not
the same one of my daughters left home
so it was like I lost too but obviously
she's she couldn't cope with even being
at home in the area it's really
shattered us as a family in North London
officers are trying to contain a fight
involving a gang of East European men
they've made several arrests so mark
this is that so
partly there was an altercation it
started off as a criminal damage think
to a motor vehicle and an argument
ensued and apparently this was pulled
and threatened and this is when the
officers hit their emergency button to
get out here and as you can see you know
it's quite a few police officers here
now solutely take control of situation
from baseball bats to knives even guns
gangs across the country are
increasingly turning to deadly weapons
to settle arguments after years of
falling crime levels violence including
knife crime is on the rise again we are
concerned about the supply of knives at
street level and one of the purposes of
this operation is not only to target
people who might be carrying knives but
also to look at places where lives might
be supplied from and we're doing a lot
of work with retailers to that end to
try and reduce the flow of knives
including these so called zombie slayer
knives that we have seen more frequently
in recent times
the two young man in this car were among
several we saw stopped and searched they
told us they understood the necessity
for such operations there's more than
enough young people dying old people
dying from livers knives guns fighting
whatever etc so if it wasn't for these
guys Gladio run if you may him so I'm
grateful that they are here sometimes
did you get on nerves because you know
don't worry in the cold all day but they
had to do Dublin back on the streets the
task force is enroute to help local
officers in East London deal with
large-scale violence one young man has
been shot
another stabbed in retaliation the duty
inspector Hackney border has requested
more units including the commissioners
reserved us due to serious disorder what
happened the nature of that disorder we
don't know yet but we've been informed
by our inspector we need to make our way
please place suspect with a knife that
is a large crowd as reinforcements
arrive to disperse groups of youths
various weapons have been seized
including this knife there's been quite
serious assaults and we are getting that
tips attacked gang mentality but seeking
retribution in the same for this mate
police task force it was a relentless
night of dealing with the consequences
of knife crime and gang violence across
the country this week there will be many
more operations like this one as police
fight back against a growing menace mark
white Sky News